how's it going I'm Gabe Hill writer and
I deflated those balls footballs huh
what footballs welcome to hashtag news
seeing as how the 50th Super Bowl is
this Sunday I thought it'd be fun to
celebrate these 50 years of greatness by
going back and comparing the early years
of the Super Bowl to this year's
monumental Super Bowl 50 it's 49 for
Super Bowl wasn't even called the Super
Bowl since it was really just a vanity
game to bring together the two
completely separate football leagues
that competed for the spot would this
supposed best of the world championship
game was kind of a bust since one of the
league's was much better than the other
and eventually just absorb the other
league entirely side note this is
exactly like what happened in the 90s
with the WWF and its legacy of badass
superstars like Hulk Hogan Stone Cold
Steve Austin and the rock and then the
super lame WCW and their knockoff
wrestlers like glacier glacier anyway
the game used to be called the afl-nfl
World Championship and today we call it
the Super Bowl
see it used to have a different name
times have changed
isn't this fun so the Super Bowl wasn't
always the huge event that it is today
Super Bowl 1 it didn't even sell out of
the 94 thousand seats in LA Coliseum
only a little more than half of the
cameras actually struggled to show the
path of the soaring footballs well still
hiding all the empty seats meanwhile
today the game definitely is sold out
despite tickets being sold for nearly
15-hundred dollars on average according
to Forbes the game has gone from the
equivalent of buying a cheap movie
ticket to I'm divorcing you because you
spent $5,000 on a football game one
reason the show is blown up is the
success of the mini concert called the
halftime show this year's show will
feature international superstar Katy
Perry accompanied by the makeup artists
from The Hunger Games viewers of the
first Super Bowl however were treated to
the smooth sounds of Grambling State
University Marching Band accompanied by
a guy with a trumpet
let's talk about the reason almost 40%
of people say they watch the Superbowl
the commercials while giving a 30-second
spot in this year's Super Bowl will cost
companies over four million dollars the
same length spot in 1967 was kind of
steel at 40 mm I'd pay that if I could
send my commercial back 50 years 48 but
it's Super Bowl 50 49 okay so how's that
48 years can you move on drop-top playas
sure we all know that modern NFL players
are major celebrities though not always
for the best reasons okay limply from
the book with a murmur number but along
with their tremendous popularity has
come a tremendous pay increase the
average salary for a football player in
1967 was $25,000 a year today's average
player though makes two million dollars
and someone like Atlanta Falcons
quarterback Matt Ryan makes over 24
million dollars a year that's 62 times
what the president makes or 331 times
what a cancer research scientist makes
Dra isn't this fun at the first Super
Bowl a heavy o-line player might have
weighed in at 250 pounds while still
nothing a buck at current NFL defensive
tackle Haloti Ngata weighs in at 340
pounds that's like making those first
Super Bowl players I'll give piggyback
rides to tyrion lanister and yet some
still expect them to run 40 yards in
under five seconds which Haloti Ngata
does oh yeah and all that mass and speed
means a modern NFL tackle shatters your
bones with the force of a minor car
accident and it kind of touches you all
right sports fans that's it for this
episode of hash tag news like this video
if you're excited about Super Bowl 50
yeah comment on this video to tell us
your favorite Super Bowl commercial mine
is when Mean Joe green makes that little
kid wash its dirty uniform
and subscribe for more hashtag news I'm
Gabe hole writer and I'll see you at the
Superbowl party though when you're going
to I'll be there I go to all of them
every year
Super Bowl 50